-Avant de se lancer en politique,
mon invité l'a d'abord observée.
C'était d'ailleurs son métier
et c'est peut-être ce qui lui a
permis ensuite de s'imposer
là où on ne l'attendait pas
forcément.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Frédéric Valletoux.
-Bonjour.
-Pendant longtemps,
on vous a connu
avec une autre casquette,
celle de président
de la FHF, la Fédération
hospitalière de France,
de 2011 à 2022.
Vous étiez un peu
le M. Hôpital,
si on veut,
et ça vous a valu
d'être très sollicité
dans les médias,
notamment
pendant toute la période du Covid.
*-La mairie de Paris propose
un confinement de 3 semaines.
C'est la bonne solution ?
Il aurait fallu reconfiner
dès aujourd'hui
dans ces territoires ?
*-Jusqu'à quand l'hôpital
peut tenir
dans cette situation ?
Que fait-on
pour accélérer
cette campagne de vaccination ?
*-On donne plus de vaccins.
Les chaînes logistiques existent.
Dans ma ville, je pourrais vacciner
4 ou 5 fois plus de personnes
avec plus de vaccins.
-Ce petit montage montre
qu'on vous a interrogé
sur tous les sujets possibles.
Confiner ? Déconfiner ?
Reconfiner ?
L'hôpital va-t-il tenir ?
Et même, que pensez-vous
du professeur Raoult ?
Comment on fait
pour répondre quand on a
ni formation médicale
ni passé de directeur d'hôpital,
qu'on est un ancien journaliste ?
-Déjà, on évacue
toutes les questions
qui touchent vraiment
à la médecine.
-Oui.
-J'ai toujours...
J'ai toujours veillé
à ne pas répondre à des questions
qui s'adressaient d'abord
aux médecins,
que je ne suis pas.
Et je n'ai jamais eu
la prétention
de les remplacer. Mais parler
de l'organisation des soins,
de la place de l'hôpital
dans le système de santé
pendant le Covid,
des tensions que vivait l'hôpital,
de la manière
dont on peut mieux répartir
entre les hôpitaux
et les cliniques
la médecine de ville,
la mobilisation de tous.
Ca, ce sont des questions
d'organisation
qui en appelaient d'abord,
sans doute,
à mon expérience de maire.
-Parce que les maires siègent
aux conseils d'administration...
-Dans les organes
de gouvernance,
aux conseils de surveillance
des hôpitaux...
J'ai présidé mon hôpital
depuis 2006
et c'est d'ailleurs
à travers...
cette présidence
que je me suis intéressé à la FHF.
D'ailleurs, elle n'est pas
toujours composée
ni que de directeurs
ni que de médecins.
Un tiers du conseil
d'administration,
ce sont des élus locaux.
Ils sont partie prenante.
Cette fédération a toujours été
présidée par un élu.
-Oui, mais souvent
des élus médecins.
Votre prédécesseur
était cardiologue...
-C'était le seul.
-...votre successeur était
praticien.
Pendant votre présidence,
vous avez affronté Olivier Véran
et Jean-Louis Touraine,
qui sont quand même des médecins.
-Claude Evin a été président
de la FHF...
-Ca remonte !
-Il a été ministre de la Santé,
mais pas médecin.
Il y a aussi Gérard Larcher,
qui a présidé la FHF.
-Il est médecin des animaux.
-Il est vétérinaire.
Il n'est pas médecin non plus.
-Comment vous avez fait
pour vous imposer dans ce milieu
médical, hospitalier,
sans avoir
de formation, de compétence ?
Il a fallu convaincre
les gens que vous étiez
la bonne personne,
malgré tout ?
-Quand on préside
une association comme la FHF,
qui regroupe tous les hôpitaux
et tous les EHPAD
- c'est l'offre de santé publique
qui est au sein de la FHF -,
c'est pas une instance médicale...
-C'est avant tout
de la politique
quand on préside la FHF ?
-Bien sûr. On est l'interlocuteur
des pouvoirs publics,
mais aussi de l'ensemble
de l'écosystème de l'hôpital,
pour parler de problématiques
de financement, d'organisation,
entre la médecine de ville
et l'hôpital,
de décloisonnement.
On parle aussi bien
avec des architectes
qu'avec des médecins
parce que la dimension médicale
est importante.
Peut-être que ceux
qui ont voté pour moi,
ils ont trouvé chez moi
peut-être des qualités
de facilitateur
entre ces communautés.
Le monde hospitalier est pluriel,
depuis les professeurs de médecine
des plus grands hôpitaux
jusqu'aux généralistes
qui gèrent des urgences
en zones rurales jusqu'aux élus
de divers niveaux.
Il y a une communauté
qui est très large.
Il y a aussi
des associations de patients.
Peut-être que l'élu,
c'est celui qui arrive...
-A faire le lien.
Vous avez eu plusieurs rôles.
Pendant 15 ans, au début
de votre carrière, vous avez été
journaliste aux Echos,
à la Gazette des communes
également.
Pourquoi ne pas se lancer
politique dès le début ?
-Au bout d'un moment,
ça m'a travaillé.
On se lève pas un matin
en voulant abandonner
15 ans de carrière
pour se lancer en politique.
C'est quelque chose
qui a mûri progressivement.
Je pense que le lien
entre ces deux moments de ma vie,
c'est évidemment l'intérêt
pour la chose publique,
pour les débats publics,
pour la politique. Pendant 15 ans,
j'ai été observateur,
un analyste...
modestement, à mon niveau,
mais en tout cas
comme observateur
de ce qu'était le débat public.
Et puis, à un moment,
j'ai voulu peut-être
être plus acteur,
me dire : "Finalement, le goût
de la politique doit amener
"à franchir le pas
et à servir l'intérêt général
"de cette manière-là."
-Ca, vous l'avez fait en 2001,
en vous mettant sur la liste
aux municipales
d'un ancien journaliste télé,
Jean-François Robinet,
à Fontainebleau. Vous aviez
conscience qu'en faisant ça,
vous alliez peut-être
être amené à renoncer
au métier de journaliste ?
-Je l'avais fait d'abord
en plein accord
avec mes supérieurs,
dans le titre que je servais,
Les Echos,
à l'époque.
Mais c'était un modeste rôle
de conseil municipal.
Mais bon,
c'était déjà mettre
un doigt de pied
dans le sujet.
J'avais conscience
que ça pouvait
m'emmener plus loin ?
Pas vraiment, à l'époque.
Les choses se sont
précipitées
dans les années 2004-2005.
-En 2005.
2005, exactement.
-Il y a eu une élection
partielle à Fontainebleau.
-Ca a été un coup de théâtre.
Crise politique locale,
le maire démissionne
et vous surgissez de nulle part.
-J'étais élu municipal
depuis 3-4 ans.
-Vous n'étiez pas attendu.
Et vous vous êtes imposé
une fois de plus,
un peu comme à la FHF,
là où on vous attendait pas.
-Je ne sais pas.
En tout cas, j'ai peut-être
convaincu les électeurs.
-Visiblement, oui.
-J'ai eu la majorité,
donc convaincu
les électeurs qu'ils pouvaient
me faire confiance.
A l'époque,
j'étais plus jeune,
j'étais un visage nouveau
dans la scène politique locale.
Les choses ont fonctionné
et ça a été un moment de bascule.
Donc voilà, ça fait...
C'était il y a 17-18 ans.
-Vous êtes resté maire
de Fontainebleau
jusqu'en 2022,
jusqu'à votre élection.
Mais entre les deux,
vous êtes présenté
2 fois aux législatives,
en dissidence
avec votre groupe
de l'époque,
qui était l'UMP.
Vous étiez engagé à droite
On ne dirait pas comme ça,
mais derrière votre côté
souriant, jovial,
finalement, il y a un rebelle.
Candidat dissident.
-Un rebelle,
je ne sais pas.
J'ai été élu la première fois
sans étiquette.
J'ai toujours été
de centre droit d'affinité,
mais très européen.
Je n'avais pas d'étiquette
politique. Bien sûr,
quand je faisais du journalisme,
je ne militais pas.
Après mon élection,
j'ai rejoint l'UMP,
quand c'était la promesse
d'être une CDU française,
avec des courants gaulliste,
libéral et centriste.
-Les Allemands.
-Les chrétiens-démocrates allemands,
c'était l'alliance
de la droite et du centre.
On connaît l'histoire.
Progressivement,
cette maison s'est rétractée.
Mais au début, c'était pour ça.
-Et le rebelle, alors ?
-Le rebelle, c'est simplement
que j'étais persuadé...
-Vous êtes ambitieux ?
Vous forcez le destin ?
-Peut-être mettre
le pied dans la porte
quand on n'est pas invité
du banquet.
Mais en tous les cas,
voilà.
C'est aussi la fougue
d'un jeune en politique.
J'avais une quarantaine d'années,
mais j'étais jeune dans...
dans l'élection.
Donc c'est peut-être
cet enthousiasme-là
qui m'a donné envie.
Je voyais bien aussi
qu'être député-maire,
lorsqu'on gérait une ville
avec peu de moyens,
mais de grandes ambitions,
pouvait être un levier
supplémentaire...
-Pour servir Fontainebleau.
-J'ai vu que le député
qui m'avait battu
me mettait des bâtons
dans les roues.
J'ai bien vu qu'il y avait
intérêt à avoir le levier
national pour aider une ville.
-Vous parliez de votre enthousiasme
pour ces législatives.
En 2022, ça semblait
être moins le cas.
Vous y êtes allé à reculons.
C'est l'impression que ça donne.
Vous vous êtes présenté
pour Horizons, cette fois,
le groupe d'Edouard Philippe,
assez tardivement
et en disant :
"La fonction de maire est plus
passionnante et concrète."
Sous-entendu : vous n'aviez pas
une très haute idée
du mandat de député.
Vous avez changé d'avis depuis ?
-D'abord, je l'ai fait avec envie
puisque j'y suis allé.
Mais je rappelle
que les investitures ont été données
après la présidentielle,
donc tant que je n'avais pas
d'investiture,
je n'en parlais pas.
Les choses ont pu
donner l'impression
que j'y allais peut-être
sans enthousiasme.
Après, je pense que la fonction
de maire est la plus riche,
la plus épanouissante et finalement,
la plus concrète aussi
dans les mandats
du monde politique.
C'est éminemment concret.
Vous touchez à la vie
de vos concitoyens,
de la naissance
jusqu'à la mort,
avec la gestion du cimetière
et des affaires funéraires.
A tous les âges
de la vie,
vos concitoyens croisent
le maire,
ces services, et c'est éminemment
concret et passionnant.
Je ne suis pas là
pour vanter Fontainebleau,
mais la ville
est passionnante.
-Vous avez trouvé votre place,
votre utilité de député ?
Vous êtes un parmi 577.
Vous n'êtes pas seul
aux commandes,
comme à la mairie.
-Je me suis engagé
derrière Edouard Philippe.
Il était dans un parcours
qui m'intéressait.
Depuis le début, on se connaît
et on a beaucoup échangé
sur ses choix de créer Horizons
et de s'engager.
Je l'ai fait pour continuer
à servir le Sud Seine-et-Marne
et Fontainebleau.
Et c'était aussi l'occasion
pour moi de plonger
dans les probl... dans les dossiers
et les enjeux nationaux.
Est-ce que j'ai trouvé ma place ?
C'est un peu tôt pour le dire.
Et puis, on voit
que dans le contexte politique
de l'Assemblée,
il n'y a pas de place stable.
Tout bouge tout le temps.
-En préparant cette émission,
j'ai été surpris de découvrir
qu'il y a très peu
de choses écrites sur vous,
peu de portraits,
contrairement à la plupart
des députés.
Vous vous méfiez
des journalistes ?
-Non, je me méfie pas
des journalistes.
Je suis porte-parole
de mon groupe...
-Vous n'aimez pas parler de vous.
-Je n'aime pas trop.
-Et pourquoi ?
Par peur d'offrir des prises
à vos adversaires ?
-Non, ça n'a pas un intérêt
phénoménal, selon moi.
Je peux parler de moi,
sans problème.
Je n'ai rien de particulier
à cacher, mais simplement,
on fait pas de la politique
pour parler de soi.
-C'est pour être dans l'action ?
-C'est pour les idées
et l'action.
-On va passer notre quiz,
si vous le voulez bien.
Le principe :
je vais commencer des phrases
et vous devrez les compléter.
On y va.
"Les journalistes devraient..."
-Devraient veiller à posséder
une culture politique
qui leur permettrait
de comprendre le temps long
de manière à pouvoir concilier
à la fois
ce qui est l'instant présent,
mais les lignes de force
de longue durée.
Ca permet d'expliquer
certaines choses.
-"En 2027,
"Edouard Philippe..."
-Sera candidat
à la présidentielle.
En tout cas, moi,
je le souhaite.
-Président...
-On fera tout pour,
mais déjà candidat,
ce serait bien.
-"Un ministre de la Santé doit..."
-Pas forcément être un docteur.
On est dans un secteur
où les corporatismes sont importants
et on le voit dès qu'on veut
bouger les lignes.
-Comme pas la FHF.
-Oui.
On met pas un agriculteur
au ministère de l'Agriculture.
Les exemples sont nombreux.
Pas de militaire à la Défense.
-Pourquoi ?
-Il faut savoir se détacher
des corporatismes.
Ca, c'est la première chose.
Et puis,
un bon ministre de la Santé
doit être quelqu'un qui doit
être capable d'être un peu
volontariste et audacieux.
S'il y a un secteur
des politiques publiques
qui est très sclérosé,
c'est les politiques de santé.
-Vous dressez votre portrait.
-Pas forcément.
-Un peu.
Ca vous intéresserait ?
-Beaucoup de gens s'y connaissent
et ne sont pas du milieu.
-C'est votre ambition,
ministre de la Santé ?
-On verra. Ca, là-dessus,
je ne sais pas.
D'Edouard Philippe ? Peut-être.
-Merci beaucoup,
Frédéric Valletoux, d'être venu.
-Merci.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA